normally the the you would think that
you know a head coach is somebody who's
starts like say as a toll taker in the
pennsylvania turnpike
and then he becomes a head coach like
the man who's joining us right here on
the rich eisen show the dallas cowboys
head coach mike mccarthy how are you sir
i'm doing well rich how are you doing
that's a great introduction i'm serious
though man you know what i mean like you
you're taking change right isn't that
what you're doing
the term excellent suburban job for
about six weeks but yes i did take
change at the
pennsylvania turnpike so what what exit
what exit were you were you working
it was exit sick or no it was exit five
back then but they they changed it to uh
the mile markers
so i'm not sure what it is okay but i
mean that and you were doing that
because you were
what you were you a grad assistant at
pitt at the time is that what you were
doing
i was actually a volunteer assistant i
just grad i just graduated from
fort hay state university in kansas
and uh got my master's degree out there
and then i was volunteering at pitt so i
did that
during the summer um just you know prior
to the 89 season
what is it about coaching what is it i
mean because
honestly you didn't you didn't have to
get back into it but you did
and i mean obviously there is no more
plum job certainly in the national
football organ football as the head
coach of the dallas cowboys but what is
it about coaching
mike mccarthy that you just some because
i see it from mooch
you know i see it from so many of my
colleagues that i work with it's so
tough to get out of your system
out of your blood what is it well i
think like all of us i mean it starts
back
in in your youth is you're part of
you're part of a team
and there's i think outside of your
family
there's not more special than being part
of a of a football team you know just
the
the camaraderie the everyday that you
know the work ethic that
and the commitment that goes into you
know doing hard stuff
with with a with a bunch of people you
respect
so um that's i think that's a part of
what drives all of us
so let's talk about um the kid that you
drafted
in the first round we had micah parsons
on a few days before the draft
i he had me at hello i love the kid i
mean like
honestly like he and then you know i i
i think he almost put the commissioner
in traction to be honest with you when
he jumped in his arms
i don't know if the commissioner wants
that information out there but
you know you need i don't know they
usually don't have a chiropractor back
there in the green room but i mean and
and he said he wanted to be a cowboy now
he is what was your what were your
conversations with him like
leading up to the draft and after well
definitely i mean the first thing is his
energy uh
he's he just has that impactful
you know just from the first impression
it was great to see him on tv i
i think it is hysterical i think there
will be a chiropractor at next year's
draft but
live and learn but no he's uh just had a
great visit with him and his family and
uh just just the whole the energy of
the way you know to talk about his
upbringing and his experience at penn
state
you know the year off so um he is uh
made a huge impression on us from the
from the first day and even you know
during the during the week with the
virtual meetings and so forth so
looking forward to getting him in the
rest of the draft class in here next
week well now you obviously got an alpha
and jalen smith anyway but how much are
you gonna put on his plate how much you
plan on putting on micah parsons plate
well i think i mean that's that's really
what the this offseason will be about so
i mean we
we have more depth at the linebacker
position than frankly i've ever been a
part of so we're
we're excited about you know pulling
that together you know speaking with dan
clinton and that defensive staff
actually
friday morning right after you know
micah's selection we were
you know we're diving into different
personnel groups and so forth because
you know we obviously want to make sure
we're
creating opportunities for for all of
our guys
and then the addition of dan quinn and
then the
addition of more than just micah parsons
i mean you want to talk about hitting
the draft
uh hard on one side of the ball your
first five
six picks were all on the defensive side
the sense that you're adding more youth
to the position and then
uh a defensive coordinator who acts like
he's a teenager because he's still
bouncing off the walls you know that the
concept is here
mike that this is automatically going to
change the defense
on its face the scheme will be more
attuned to what the players
who you already had in there were used
to before you
arrived uh what do you make of that
general sense
and narrative of the cowboys on the
defensive side of the ball
well i think like any time you have a
change at the head coach position
there's a
there's a vision of the football team
that that's obviously going to be
different i mean that's that's part of
why you make a change and you know upon
my arrival
uh you know one thing we wanted to to be
on defense is we wanted to have more
length and more speed
and and i think you're just really
seeing that coming to you know
you know come come into place now here
in the second year and i think the draft
definitely reflects that
and you know dan quinn brings it you
know an expertise and an energy
that we you know definitely our guys
have already bought into
uh you know our offseason program has
has been outstanding i can't say enough
about
you know the the players and the coaches
what we've been able to get done here
the first couple weeks so
uh but this this was more about changing
the division and
and how we want to play on defense and i
think we like you said i think we hit
the jackpot
in this year's draft well i mean mike
mccarthy you're the cowboys here on the
rich eisen show it's interesting you use
the word buy-in because that was part of
the conversation last year as i'm sure
you're aware
in the metroplex um that there was a
lack of buy-in
for your scheme and what you were
attempting to sell to the players that
were there do you feel
that there is a better sense on that
subject matter as we're sitting here the
following may getting ready for a 2021
season
yeah i think going back to last year i
don't know if much of it was buying i
think it was more understanding and time
together i
i think any first year head coach
would would have to say that you know
time with your players was the probably
the biggest challenge i know
i felt that way all the way from day one
i mean from the
not being able to speak to your team in
person until the first day of
training camp all the way through so um
i think we've
actually been able to establish you know
how we want to play
uh in the last eight weeks on defense
you know we finished
you know uh seventh in the league and
taking away the football so
that's a great foundation of how we will
continue to play and
so i think it's just really part of the
transition last year was more of the
transition from
you know the way defense was was viewed
and played
prior to my arrival and hopefully i i
see us taking a big step there this year
mike mccarthy dallas cowboys head coach
here on the rich eisen show how is dak
prescott coach i mean he looks great i
mean he really does i mean he's in here
every day so
um i can't say enough about the progress
he's made
you know i think it's like you know all
of us there's different thresh
thresholds you have to get over when
you're you're coming back from
from anything and you could see just his
uh
you know his ability now you know he's
throwing to the perimeter group and uh
but he's taking up
he's taking a bunch of bunch of steps
here and uh he looks great uh
we're we're excited and i think he'll be
he'll pick up right where he left off
well when would you say i know you're
not a doctor you don't play one on tv
um and and i know uh coaches do the only
control what they can control situation
but
is your expectation that uh week one
when we learn the schedule next
wednesday
and where you're gonna be um that it's
gonna be dac
for you but well you you took away all
my coaching one-on-one
so let's go to advanced learning let's
go to advanced learning well you well
you could or you could go full kyle
shannon and say that we could all be
dead by then anyway so
i'm not i'm not one to jump in a news
cycle there for a couple days
i like to get in and get out but uh
no i i i yeah i think we're right on
track i think everything that
uh you know the medical you know people
talk
as far as his rehab he's you know he'll
definitely hit the target i'm you know
i'm hopeful that
with the ota practices that he'll be in
there uh full go but you know
he he really he looks great just really
i don't think anybody has any doubt
and again i know coaches again uh you
can only control what you can control it
is what it is and all of those
101 coaching phrases though uh you
did you ever at any point during the
last few weeks months before the
contract got signed say jerry what's
another
what's another couple million come on
you know what come on
it wasn't quite like any of those words
but i was definitely in favor of getting
the contract done so
and uh that was clear and but no i i
think it's uh
you know the business part of this is is
something we all have to deal with and
some are so much more public public than
others so
yeah i think it was it was a it was a it
was a great day when his contract
was completed for everybody here mike
mccarthy here on the rich eisen show and
you have been around some very talented
players certainly on the offensive side
of the ball as we know from all your
years
in green bay with dak and zeke
and amari and gallop and obviously cd
lam and year two and i'm sure i'm
leaving off some
very important people where does this
rank for you collection of talent what
can be done
from your mind your scheme on the field
to win games and championships where
does this rank for you
well i think we definitely have have a
chance to be you know one of
the better or best groups clearly in my
time it's you know i think just really
that we're going back to time together i
mean just you know
dax just playing you know first five
games and you know keep you know blake
jarwin was was injured here in week one
so just getting all these guys on the on
the field especially with our tackles
you know tyrone and lc look great going
through the workouts
to get everybody out there you know
playing as a whole unit i think we have
a chance to be special on offense
and um you know just being the head
coach of the dallas cowboys
um you know if i again you know
obviously you've had an incredible
career
you want to talk about um you know
places where you've been
um san francisco prior to green bay and
now here to dallas the toll taker what
would the toll taker have said if i said
you're going to be the head coach the
packers
and the dallas cowboys the two when
would that happen
well i mean the the tool taking days was
really just trying to make it at the
university of pittsburgh so but
uh i think it's just a you know
an example of you know having having a
dream and and putting up putting the
work
to you know have the work ethic to chase
it and uh but yes this is um
to be the head coach of the green bay
packers and now the dallas cowboys i i
it's beyond my dreams and and it's
interesting too we were talking about
this before mike mccarthy because
uh you know my my uh social media grand
maester as he likes to be called on the
set t.j jefferson's a die-hard cowboys
fan and we were talking about
when you know people are most
disappointed by results that they got to
snap the television off they're so upset
he mentioned it was a time where dez
bryant he thought he caught it
and uh as we all know dez did not how
does it feel for you to
walk around that building being maybe
the only human being in that building
who might uh think otherwise on the
concept of whether dez caught it
mike well that's a great topic because i
think the timing of you know i think the
time has been great because they
actually changed the rules on what it
catches now in the league so that's
right uh so technically
today dez did catch it at that
particular time
he did not so and and i'm just glad
we challenged it and i'm glad it worked
out on that particular day but
i definitely understand what uh how
everybody felt on the other side
of course but so did you just both sides
the situation right there did i just
hear
that that on the day it was one thing
and now you're part of an organization
that you
can admit um you know that he did in
fact catch it
so what you're saying i thought it was
you know sam shields and dez i thought
it was two great athletes going up to
make a play on the ball and it came down
and
and i'm just thankful the game was it
was at home when i got
like 17 looks at it on the jumbotron
and i had a chance to talk to to jane
that you know about the role the catch
and so forth so it
it timing has a lot to do with those
types of things as you know
rich and uh the rules were different
back then and
it worked out so but the rules today in
today's game that would be a catch
there you go all right very good says
the coach of the dallas cowboys
right there so tj i hope that hopefully
that's that's good for you because
we we want to make sure tj's okay uh
coach because
you might not be aware he was on the
prices right earlier this week
and all he came away with was a ping
pong table and a popcorn machine
he wouldn't he's part of a double over
uh at the end of the show so we're
trying to buck him up as we head to the
weekend
you know hey the more i can do for you
rich you know that's that's what i'm
here for okay appreciate that coach
there you go
there is an eye on mike but he's a team
player coach thanks for the call
appreciate it send my best to everybody
there rich dalrymple and everybody just
uh part of a great
group and crew and let's do this again
uh if you don't mind uh training camp
definitely thanks for having me alright
we'll chat with you guys cowboys there
you go
there you go that's mike mccarthy right
here on the rick johnson show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here